[Music]
hello welcome to honest trailer
commentaries for the shinning we're
gonna be talking about that film the
Australian we made for it our thought
process behind it
stick around after for some cut jokes
and a clue to next week's honest trailer
mm-hmm that's what this show is all
right let's take the shining down a pic
this is seriously one of my favorite
films probably probably sniffing my top
5 if I'm being fully honest but what do
y'all think of the shining vans it's
really good yeah I'm a fan okay and I'm
also a fan of the book do you miss the
hedge monsters the most no because they
did that in the miniseries for TV on ABC
that led they just weren't ready for
primetime yeah yeah I don't know know if
they could have made that really work in
1980 the way that the way that it should
very well they're written very it's a
great sequence in the book and like I
think today somebody clever could pull
it off but 1980 yeah yeah I like The
Shining I you know as I think everyone
knows horror movies are not my thing but
no you're making some noises yeah I got
in a couple of like oh no no I've seen
it but I just I react I'm like a child
man or like a goldfish I reacted
everything before anything past 30
seconds Danielle don't remember yeah
this man this movie does manage to kind
of lull you back in under its spell you
know it definitely scares me every time
puts me on edge time I see it just
because there's something like hypnotic
and we make fun of it because you got to
make some jokes about how let's say
deliberately paste it is right but
you're right there you really do start
to feel claustrophobic like you're
trapped in there with that family
ya know Isaac Kubrick film I love this
movie I think this is a great example of
Kubrick when you can it's weird how you
can bring this he can make a movie set
in space which is like this limitless
outer Beyond of the infinity and a movie
set entirely almost entirely inside of a
hotel and still give the same mystery to
both of them it
really like just shows you how first
Olli was a filmmaker those are you use
the word deliberate which I think yeah
like he's making movies that are there
they take their time they're patient
they they're they build atmosphere but
they're not boring it's not slow or dull
everything that's happening is
interesting the filmmaking and the
technique the performances he there's
enough there to carry you along I think
2001 Clockwork Orange you made a lot of
films like that that are like they took
the time they're not even Eyes Wide Shut
like they take their time they're not
like kinetic hyper excitement but it's
never a slog you're never bored now this
film though a lot of the reviews when it
came out did say it was boring and like
what's happening and so unsatisfying
what an anticlimax it's just interesting
I think maybe the expectations
surrounding this movie when it came out
and just being a horror film what
critics were expecting going in it was
not yeah we we talked to we were to the
writing it didn't make the final Jeff
but Shelley Duvall and Stanley Kubrick
were nominated for a Razzie Awards
namely first year was no need for a
worst director Razzie award and Shelley
Duvall was nominated for worst actress
because this movie was very this one and
movies like Empire Strikes Back which is
much more polarizing when it came out
certainly more so than star wars like a
lot of times like a last Jedi of its
time in a way just some people there's
no internet just screaming into the
overtime you know classics especially
when you look under our Tomatoes because
people go back and review them in a
forest land oh in it
that's believable Lando it makes it look
like they were universally beloved when
in fact they're much more polarizing at
the time I came out and then shining was
definitely one of those you can't fire
lightning bolts out of your hand fully
Internet was there tweeting me I ran all
right you're looking for it I wanted to
hear Twitter on everybody I expect and a
read contract that's what Twitter is no
it's Trump and the last Jedi let's
quickly segue into watching the honest
trailer for shiny cats movie and demand
it I'm glad we got to do this movie
action yeah yeah this was fun to do a
challenge but not based on the Stephen
King novel in the trash sure iconic
piece of horror cinema
that was probably scary before it got
parodied to death
yeah perfect strangers spot-on
dreamcatcher rock with my life positive
I think that the Simpsons did the best
parody by far
oh you mean yeah not really a contest I
mean over overall the Simpsons parody
it's so good that it really kind of like
melds in with the actual movie in my
mind sometimes there are definitely
times like when I'm watching The Shining
that I imagine mr. all would be like hey
tell you what we come back in their own
slaughtered I the elevator scene I was
actually pitched before remembering that
it's what mr. bird says like the blood
usually I saw that one first cuz also
gave rise to one of the most useful
every day since the quotes urge to queue
[Music]
building yes 10% he couldn't just that
roadrunner scene yeah
Oh Kevin on the music just up here yeah
characters pulling a crazy face I mean
he's got the best crazy yeah yeah good
crazy characters there's a lot of
wandering yeah yeah got that set though
it was a set by the way yeah they're
right applause sorry boring
behind the scenes info about the shining
though but they built that on a
soundstage and the set was apparently
incredibly hot because they had this
they had to blast so much light through
those big windows we could see outside
yeah that it was just like I didn't know
that very very warm I knew they built a
set and like we'll get into some of the
fan theories and stuff like that in room
237 of people like the hotel is
impossible like you walk around rooms
and there's a window or should be it's
like a lot of this movie was intentional
and there are things I think he's
seeding in there but the fact that the
layout doesn't make sense is cuz it's a
set it's not a real hotel exteriors a
real place called the Stanley Hotel
that's still there well the Stanley
actually it's a real one that's the one
they used for the TV show but right I
remember more succinctly as the movie
where Harry and Lloyd stated dumb and
dumber Harry and Lloyd stay is the
Stanley Hotel we didn't feel real
haunted hotel that Stephen King stayin
that inspired the show is it really in
Aspen where the beers in Colorado I
don't know probably breckenridge
breckenridge forget were the one from
the movie yeah the actual exterior the
Portland like Pacific Northwest where I
think it might be I'm not sure but
anyways the the idea that like oh they
that office is impossible given that
hallways because it was all built on a
soundstage
yeah I mean they get real caught up in
like Danny riding his tricycle like some
of that stuff should be on different
floors like you shouldn't be able to do
that maybe you can brick put that in
there
it's like the impossible physics your
mind would but it's also possible there
was just like well it's a movie yeah you
that because the set was all one floor
right you're not really tell ya all
right keep going
jump-scare in the livery on top of an
Indian burial ground with a long history
of murderer so like a nice motel 6 the
winter caretaker
jack nickel tour ends with a book is a
loving family man who slowly goes mad
over the course of the season as the
dark secrets of the Overlook are
revealed
pause yeah I saw a little push back on
that thing like that's not it that's not
an accurate depiction of his character
in the book you know because they're
like they talk about in the first
whatever pages that he broke his son's
arm and it's like yeah but like the
point being in the book he did do that
stuff but like he is in recovery he very
desperately wants to be a family man he
is very loving and caring toward his
family he has flashes of that temper but
the whole story is about him being
corrupted over a very long course of
many many months as he's in the basement
going under these over these books and
about the hotel influencing them or is
it or is he just a hopeless alcoholic
who's no Jack Torrance is a monster from
the start
right this movie healing he he doesn't
really show much warmth ever toward his
family and yeah we never get to know him
apart I mean when the movie opens he's
already there like he's yeah like the
Overlook has could taking over his mind
essentially from the very beginning play
girl in the lobby he's he's just a mad
dog and his family I mean it's clear
that Kubrick did do that intentionally
he didn't want you to get to see any
other version Jack Torrance other than
this one and it is very different it's a
it's a descent into madness I pushed
back on the push back and I will say
that the beginning of the book The
Shining Jack Torrance is a man with
demons certainly demons but who
legitimately and genuinely wants to
reform and be a family and just trying
very hard and just the the tragedy of
the book is you watch this man just
self-destruct and collapse on himself
it's a very familiar Stephen King theme
about a person battling their personal
demons and am I defined by these
horrible urges or am i you know can I
become them movie Jack has always been
part of the over like I feel like I've
always been here yeah the part of this
place so right yes he's he's already
kind of over his family even as they're
driving I always forget like the scene
where he's just like when you hear this
like that's early yeah that's like
that's like acts 3 Jack from the book
that's like early act 2 he's like don't
it's like yeah no he's he's long gone
yeah man in my position yeah yeah he
doesn't do any actual caretaking that he
is making such a big deal of his own
importance when she's doing his job and
he's waking up at 11:00 that stuff you
know and again in the book like that
role he is critically like if he doesn't
do his job the hotel will literally
explode right and so that's the whole
thing like they can't leave and they're
arguing what she tells him to leave it's
just like oh so you want me to just
leave and this place explodes it burns
down because they have to empty the
boiler it's like it's not what you want
and I mean it's like it's much more you
know it's a lot deeper yeah the movie in
the book are two different animals well
we can talk by later but I think there
is I think there is a deeper point being
made in the movie than the kind of
typical not typical but like the reverse
hero's journey going on in the book of
like oh he's a good man being corrupted
in this one I think this is a very
symbolic movie and what it's symbolic oh
yeah up for based on the book but I
would say it's not representative oh it
looks like inspired yes it's good let's
continue
he never really liked his family
I mean we don't know how long they've
been in the car at that point so a few
hours drive yeah okay that was the pause
for one second that would that film I
think set the record for like a shot
with dialogue the number of takes oh
yeah
taken it was in the hundreds up and down
the something down yeah like trying to
actually drive them insane and same with
like some of the shots with the Scatman
Crothers with him and Danny like Cooper
yeah it was borderline if not abuse the
part of this he was trying to
psychologically break down
it was certainly psychological abuse
yeah I think there's any question about
it particularly Shelley Duvall and
Scatman Crothers like he them down
mentally yeah to get them where they
needed to be and I think there's a whole
discussion to be had about whether that
should be a valid study why it's not
that was an idea that has kind of weaved
itself through Hollywood history
Hitchcock also there's a lot of stories
just using similar tactics and I think
we're definitely in a different time now
where that is it's a defense of
Hitchcock or Kubrick but now definitely
that sort of behavior tire your actors
to act I think now we've come across
come along to this idea that well that
the director's job is to sort of help
the actors do their job and not to try
to like trick or manipulate them into
getting the best performance now what do
you make of like a leo chowing down on
bison liver cuz he like hates himself
yeah I'm Yuri too is not like listen you
get up there get in that horse we didn't
talk about this until just this moment
but now I in says alright that's the
making of the shining it's on not to
endorse cuz I don't know if you can
actually buy it but just google it it's
on the Internet
it's also available as supplementary
features various it's it's not a lot of
different range official Asian google it
so that you may click the link to
purchase below but it was made by
Kubrick's daughter and it's just her
wandering around the set of The Shining
like filming Jack as he's getting into
character and just like being a very
famous clip of Nicholson and he's
holding the axe like getting ready
it's fascinating if you're if you're
Shelley Duvall I think talks about like
her hair started coming out air is
coming out she was put to the readers
and Stanley's like oh okay long shoot
yeah under constant pressure he's
rolling his eyes at hurts and saying
that my hair is falling out but yeah he
wanted to literally isolate her so that
she felt isolated you go through all of
that your hair falls out and then you
get nominated for a Razzie
boy oh pretty bad anyways then you make
Nursery Rhyme adaptations for a whole
generation of chiloé well Shelley Duvall
yeah that's alright first yeah the whole
generation met Shelley Duvall that one
guys are old he never acted again must
have had a lot of fun beforehand I know
I'm particularly fast now that's like
dying twice experience this complex and
baffling masterpiece that could be an
allegory for anything the treatment of
Native Americans alcoholism fate versus
free will alienation writers Bob DC is
in the minotaur the Illuminati it's all
the dream Kubrick's confession for
faking the moon landing MKULTRA they're
in Helen Jack's through the Holocaust
the patriarchy the destruction of
Kubrick's old neighborhood a warning
about staying in the bathtub all the
importance of regular snowcat
maintenance code you guys will talk
about the theories no elaborate
backstories or explanations and no
unstoppable monsters just a sad dad was
killed by the wrong choice of jacket if
he took Scott man's jacket he would have
gained it out on her key version of let
us know
[Music]
pause jump-scare come on Lonnie pause -
sorry let's see the jump-scare yeah
[Music]
alright pause yeah I was in the lab with
Kevin our editor get him to make
jump-scare cheesier and worse because he
his instincts were good and were to make
something like cinematic and had some
building tension but I was like no
pretend you're a can of Mountain Dew
with Lego you do the earthquake effect
and make it turn red and do like pretend
you're making like the follow-up to the
nun versus La Llorona that trailer jump
scare yeah this I think this would have
been the perhaps in a different time
marketed a certain way and viewed much
like a movie like hereditary or it comes
at night where it's Martin Luther
there's a mainstream Heart home and then
people go see it they're like today I
feel like if this came out today this
would be one of those like it got a 97
from critics but a 43 this is getting a
D+ CinemaScore yes it could probably
done like - the movie star it could be
done for a low-budget like probably
Amazon Prime everybody watch The Shining
over that three-day weekend sound like
the BBC iPlayer and you watch it but
maybe we'll come in Netflix soon yeah
well but yeah I mean even then it like I
said it confounded critics when it came
out so expectations were we're all over
the place yeah Cooper movies tend to be
like that I mean even Eyes Wide Shut the
the most recent one after his legendary
icon status was permanently cemented
even that got mixed reviews when it
opened it was only years later that
people went back and sort of all agreed
that it's pretty good we should do that
on the Strand that'd be fun let's do
shining is a movie that came out a 1980
I was born in 83 and I think in in my
conscious lifetime The Shining is a
movie that I don't think was canonized
but it has now become canonized like for
a long time it was remembered as like
here's Johnny and it's like a really
good horror movie but I think really in
the last 20 or so years is when it's
like actually become like not just a
popular movie and you've got it on your
wall or whatever but like it's become
canonized and you see it more and more
regarded as I think it is horror movie
ever yeah and it's the rise of armchair
film analysis which we've made careers
off of of people just being like well
actually the shining is about blood like
did you know Star Wars is about genocide
like whatever it's it's definitely a
take friendly like generator take
culture definitely benefits from movies
like The Shining runs on takes takes all
right let's actually pause one second if
we can't go back to the shining coming
soon if this were a modern horror movie
it would have like WWE the shining movie
2019 dot-com hashtag Jack's back only it
would just be like an ad for the
Overlook Hotel and you'd have to click
in its like oh there were ghosts in that
movie yes the emoji xanax
máximo G comes out anyways all right
keep goin tight so prop still on for
that one it's not all about sex just
even complete control masterpiece
Stephen King looks like in the 80s
who's the a hole and die hard that tries
to negotiate Ellis Ellis looks like
Ellis and Harry I only know him as the
guy from Supergirl oh yeah he is he's
the lemon just super this is Ellis from
die hard yes he weighs like a dopey
construction work no no okay Wow I have
CW get it know the movie
[Laughter]
alright let's hop into some make it its
way in some day that's my car from rainy
dark place you know what's really scary
how hard it was to find porn in the
seventies up in the corner of a car
rental place read straight copies of
Playgirl no way was that
please take girl yes yeah it is Playgirl
okay yes I I noticed that well I was I
was like wait girl I only read it for
the articles
speaking of which one of the articles on
that cover is about family sexual abuse
which gives credence to the theory that
he sexually abused Danny because he's
lying on this big teddy bear and he
changed it from a dog to a bear and the
BJC that's like going on which brings us
to our fan quest yeah you're room 237
Jason Georgie's right switch Ludacris
room 237 interpretation of the shining
is your favorite I mean from sheer
ludicrous a it's got to be the moon land
the idea of Stanley Kubrick being the
one who faked the moon landing is itself
so silly and elaborate the moon landing
you don't need the greatest director
like it shouldn't be the greatest
filmmaker you would want a guy like
directs TV like make it more realistic
well and also with that I mean it's
unrealistic for a billion reasons we had
the guy who did 2001 who made you know
he can do the job you don't want it to
look like a space movie cast moon
landing doesn't look like 2001 it looks
like TV footage right now I also have
the idea that he would be apologizing
publicly for this monstrosity of a
comprar that if it were to become public
would it would color the the public's
perception of the government of
everything for life and that he would be
so unsettled to actually put on Apollo
11 rocket on Danny's I think also like
the idea that it's I mean look you can
read this as theseus and the minotaur
because he's chasing somebody around
amazed at the end but they look at that
that poster that skiing poster of them
in one shot in the room and like if you
squint it looks like a bull so it's like
it's the Minotaur there you go there it
is there's a gun solved weird side fact
I actually recreated that in college
that Theseus in a Minotaur for this
thing that I was I was it was a project
about how Greek myth and chorus turned
into eventually theater in plays and
stuff like recreated yeah okay
I sucked fine
I actually think that the the Native
American is like colonial interpretation
is probably what he was seeding in there
I think with like the amount of American
flags that it's built on top of a Native
American resting place that it's being
huh its July 4th in that final photo at
the end yeah the the Overlook itself has
all sorts of tapestries Native designs
and yeah
the fact he's like out of nowhere he
starts talking about the white man's
burden he's at the bar I think that
that's probably uh probably what he
thought was interesting I think I think
there is it's purposefully vague it's
purposefully ambiguous there's
purposefully a lot of different ideas
going on because I think he wanted you
to read in whatever you wanted to into
it you know I think it's about all of
these things yeah it is a pretty another
movie to project whatever your own stuff
is on upon it mm-hmm yeah well there you
go let's see what else we got here
Rebecca be was that Joe singing asked
was that Joe singing let it snow now
that was John John's a man and many
voices yeah including minor key versions
of let's see Brandon Vasquez writes who
came up with that Aerosmith joke it was
pretty funny Dan that was that was me I
have blood and elevator
you saw our alternates that didn't make
the cuz I don't that I mean that's Aviv
to be to negging what I saw this one
word did change that's company and then
X right specs he's gonna give it to us
how do we not discuss the single biggest
mystery of the plot who the hell let
Jack out of the freezer if ghosts can
physically move things why didn't the
ghost keep Wendy and Danny inside the
hotel he goes it's not the ghost
let's let him out I guess maybe the
mystery I'll restate it in a different
way why did the ghost
choose why did they do that when they
had the motive and the opportunity to
kill them a million other different
times in ways here's yeah well I'll
besides the fact that the it's a movie
and that's just how the movie went it's
real I'm sure but no if you're gonna if
we want to go canonically well at least
according to the book which you know
Stanley Kubrick scrapped most of but the
the book explanation would be that the
The Shining the ghosts at the Overlook
act through jack so he's very much a
manifestation of all of that evil
they're able to sway him because he's
already in a very sensitive frame of
mind but they realize that Danny's power
makes them much more powerful which is
really their motivation in the book
again and in the movie that's left a
little not quite as stated but their
real motivation is for Jack to kill
Danny so that he becomes part of the
hotel and thus makes them infinitely
more powerful because he has this
special power The Shining so that they
would then be able to they could not
they were very kind of weak as far as
power goes there were echoes but they
realized that when Danny was there they
became much stronger so the the
explanation would be that Grady can do
things like open a freezer door because
they're growing in power but they did
not yet possess the power to affect
change on that kind of like they
couldn't ghosts couldn't just kill
somebody a corporeal the person they had
to go through Jack in order to do that I
think another read is that the hotel's
really not interested in the
consequences of what happens I mean it's
a hotel they're all dead there's spirits
sort of occupying this other realm
it's just corrupting Jack that it's just
it's an evil place if there's a sinister
vibe they want to corrupt people who are
susceptible to it who come in there and
so yeah they're just driving him crazy
making him kill his family and that they
have no real interest in like oh we got
to keep Wendy
here it's just how could we play on this
guy and make him crazy until he dies and
he he becomes absorbed in with the rest
of us alternate theory Danny did it hear
me out hear me out
you see Danny making his shining face
right either right before or right after
the door opens he has been abused by his
father he doesn't he has the motive and
the opportunity he doesn't want to see
them ride out the the winter with him in
the freezer and then escape to safety
where he could be hurt again he wants
him dead
he knows scat man's on the way with and
he is trying to get scat man to kill his
dad so he lets him out thinking that the
confrontation will go differently that
it won't go the way it goes okay why
would this powerful psychic allow
himself to be murdered that way surely
see a man with an axe coming a little
slow guys he was behind a pillar really
loud yeah so there you go I think Danny
did it trying to get his dad killed by
scatman because he knew he was coming to
mop things up mmm that's my ex also
positive is there anything else nope
that's it all right that's the shining I
hope you enjoyed our little chat I hope
you'll tune in next week where we have a
similar delusion over what's real and
what isn't we'll see you next time right
here on Australian commentaries bye bye
[Music]
you